homemade gnocchi making your enoki
is so simple to do yet the results are
absolutely stunning and it's a great way
of using up leftover baked potatoes
you can make noki just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it that
nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half
take your spoon and scoop the inside
of those potatoes i'm using leftover
baked potatoes
but this really works as well with
leftover ball potatoes
two choices you can get a fork and sort
of mash the potato and get it nice and
light and fluffy
or this little gadget it's called a
ricer
i suppose it's a posh word for a potato
masher
just squeeze gently you can see how nice
and light it is almost like fluffy
little strands of potato you can do this
when the potatoes are hot
it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now a nice spoon of okata rin
a little touch of salt and pepper it's
really important to season
the mixture as we go along otherwise the
nokia becomes really bland
flour over the ricotta sieved so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
[Music]
now make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft pliable ball of
dough
give that a really good mix get some
thyme flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb
and with the ricotta it tastes brilliant
just pick the little tips
the time flowers next
flour your hands generously and knead
the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet and
just add
a little touch of flour we want
something really nice and soft
now don't overwork it it stops the nokia
from
expanding when it hits the pan that's
exactly what i want
a nice sort of soft fragrant ball
cut the ball in half lightly flour
the hands and just roll it gently just
think of a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi
it doesn't stick cut the dough into
bite-sized
pieces just take your finger dip it in
the flour
and push down why i want my knocking to
look like a
pillow and for me the most important
part there is that
not one of them are identically the same
shape water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there lightly flour your
hand
lift up the noki in to the rolling
boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom
and let them simmer and they start to
sort of tell you
they're cooked when they start floating
get a pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top
and you can continue cooking them like
that i like blanching them in the water
taking them out
and then frying them to study the
gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying pan
gently lift up and look they've doubled
in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in
to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside nokia
loves
fresh pepper so
pepper in
[Laughter]
you can see as i start turning them got
this really nice little sort of
brown colour
are they almost popping up now like
little parcels
so i want them nice and sauteed both
sides but light
and creamy in the center
fresh garden peas in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful put a little bit of fresh
thyme
over the peas and then finally i want to
lift it up
fresh lemon zest the lemon over
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated parmesan cheese give
your veg some attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook
and absolutely stunning add the curry
paste and cook to release the flavors
add cubed potatoes to serve dollop the
black bean mixture
on crunchy tortillas